le parquet de Tours annonçait
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
dégradation par moyen incendiaire et
violation de domicile
après les dégradations et destructions
il faut reconstruire quatre jours après
le pillage et l'incendie déclaré dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi dans le
supermarché de Tours Nord employé et
direction sont sur le pont pour
organiser la réouverture prévue ce
mercredi il reste deux jours pour tout
remettre en ordre jeter ce qui doit
l'être et nettoyer romain Delville
le magasin saccagé pillé brûlé dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi et comme coupé
en deux ce lundi d'un côté les rayons
vidés le sucré confiserie chocolat doué
partie l'incendie par feu d'artifice les
produits frais les fruits et légumes
aussi ont été jetés à la poubelle un
propre à la consommation à cause de la
suie ton a bloqué les zones à
décontaminer
les zones en fin de compte qui ont été
touchées par l'incendie et les
émanations de gaz dues à l'incendie on
protège d'autres zones en fin de compte
pour éviter que les vapeurs qui étaient
présentes sur le site puisse aller
ailleurs donc on attend une entreprise
afin de intervenir et de nettoyer
l'ensemble complet d'un autre côté le
personnel s'active pour remettre le
magasin en état ça passe par le
nettoyage et la mise en gondole des
produits c'est le rayon alcool qui a été
le plus pillé certains employés ne
cachent pas leurs colères je suis en
train de remplir bienveillant qui ont
été saccagés par les petits bandits
comme on dit
on a fait le grand nettoyage ça se
parlait des dégâts de bouteilles
éclatées des paquets écrasés voilà
ils sont content
l'huissier est passé pour constater les
dégâts la centrale est en lien avec les
assurances mais sur place les gérants
ont le sentiment d'avoir été abandonnés
à leur sort sans soutien pendant et
après les événements pas de soutien de
de police il a fallu faire un peu par
nous-mêmes en fin de compte
alors après je peux comprendre même
l'intervention des pompiers ils sont
faits quand ils ont voulu venir donc on
s'est débrouiller par nous-mêmes
mais c'est ce que je disais quand on a
eu les politiciens qui sont venus le
vendredi enfin nos élus mais je dis ne
serait-ce qu'une alerte on a des alertes
commerciales quand il y a des
cambriolages ou quand il y a des faits
qui se passent au niveau de la ville et
là rien même pas une alerte pour nous
dire attention il y a eu ça protéger vos
commerces c'est à l'air là on l'a eu
vendredi après-midi après la réunion de
la préfecture vendredi après-midi on a
reçu une alerte protéger vos commerces
24 heures trop tard quoi on va dire quoi
qu'il en soit le magasin rouvrira ses
portes mercredi à 8h30 certains membres
du personnel expriment déjà leur
impatience de voir revenir leurs clients